combat in Star Wars Jedi fallen order
can be challenging especially once you
get through the early areas and start
encountering tougher enemies like purge
troopers and Imperial security droids to
help overcome these challenges we've
highlighted the best skills to unlock
and fall in order first
early on in fallen order you don't have
much in the way of attack or defense
other than your lightsaber and without
many options for forced abilities you'll
want to invest points into skills geared
towards increasing couch ances at
survival first you'll find these four
abilities in the first year of kal skill
trees survival skills is ideally the one
you want to unlock first you won't have
many bd1 stem canisters at the start of
fall and orders campaign having a higher
max health will help until you can
increase the number of times you can
heal
likewise force attunement is a good
choice increasing your max force pool
with those two out of the way consider
unlocking overhead slosh this powerful
move will dispatch most creatures and
standard storm troopers in one hit
though the move loses utility the
further into the game you go it's an
excellent attack to have early on once
you travel to zepho how will remember
how to use force push this unlocks
numerous skills in his lightsaber and
force trees including the final skill in
the first tier mask push if you enjoyed
Star Wars The Force Unleashed you'll
love mass push allows you to charge a
forced push and send enemies flying
ideal for zepho and Kashyyyk where enemy
placement is almost begging free
distance stormtroopers flying off ledges
to their deaths once you've made it
passes fo you'll have to start choosing
how to build Cal you should hold off on
unlocking the advanced variations of
survival skills and force attunement for
a bit it's better to invest in the
intermediate lightsaber combat skills
they will be much more useful for the
purge troopers and inquisitors you'll
soon be fighting in the lightsaber tree
unlock - strike sprint strike delay
thrust and lightsaber threat all four of
these lights he removes help you counter
the skilled defensive purge troopers and
speed of the inquisitors - strike glass
Cal to leap at his target sprint strike
let's and deliver a attack out of a
sprint delay thrust gives him some added
range to a standard attack and
lightsaber throws Cal's only
long-distance option in combat of all
four you'll have to wait longest to
unlock lightsaber throw as you cannot
unlock it until Kaori learns force full
on Kashyyyk the only force power that
reliably works on all enemies is force
love you possess force low from the
start
and it's effective right out of the gate
so it's not a skill you need to improve
right away however after the opening
hours unlocking empowered slow is wise
it's ideal for controlling a crowd
giving you time to heal or keeping a
boss from moving fast enough to block
your next attack these skills will take
you through the opening hours of all in
order by the time you unlock all of them
you should have a pretty good idea of
what your ideal fighting style is as
well as which of Cal's advanced skills
you want to start investing in you're
still having trouble in the first few
hours of falling order be sure to check
out our beginner's guide
[Music]